I want to talk about those four points
that I made earlier because
I was actually going to do a video on
this the other day
I was going to throw the GoPro up in the
car and just do it on the entrepreneurs
and cars Channel but
so the four main risk exposures that you
have are competition anxiety is going to
relax betaization through a thousand
concessions is a real issue your frame
control needs to go up pretty
dramatically if you're an unplugged
Alpha and you're going to have legal
issues which I'll explain last so first
thing let's let's deal with competition
anxiety so what is competition anxiety
when you're dating a woman and you're
going about your life you're doing your
work you're going to the gym you're
hitting the dojo you're hanging out with
your friends you're doing your hobbies
hanging out with your boys with the
Exotic Car Club stuff
and then you're seeing her you know on
the days and nights and you know
weekends or whatever that you're hanging
out
the times that you're not with her
women have competition anxiety for you
competition for your attention your time
and it's not just other women it's the
people you're with you know friends and
stuff like that she doesn't know what
you're up to she doesn't know where
you're at she doesn't know who's there
you know this is why when women you know
when you're dating like when you live
together one of the things that will
relax is she doesn't creep you as much
which could be a pro work on but women
will creep the [ __ ] out of a guy that
they are head over heels for right if
you're her Apex Alpha if you're the guy
that she sees as her hypergamous best
option she's going to Folly very closely
and what you're doing with your online
footprint mostly on social media
um who likes your post who follows you
who comments on your [ __ ] right and then
she'll dive into all their stuff oh did
he comment on her stuff is he following
her does he like her stuff why you know
that competition anxiety
which is a good thing Believe It or Not
relax is almost completely when you guys
live together because she knows where
you are at all times she knows that she
is beside you in that bed every night
okay she knows where she knows when you
get up she knows when you make your
coffee she knows when you take your
first [ __ ] she knows what you eat for
breakfast she knows everything about you
so
having a little bit of mystery in the
relationship is good for the
relationship because it keeps things a
little bit strange it keeps her and you
to some degree both of you on your toes
um you don't make as many mistakes and
to be honest neither does she so having
a little bit of competition anxiety is a
good thing too much of it can be a bad
thing because it could drive her nuts
right like she'll just go into like a
jealous rage and just make your life
miserable uh but when you live together
competition at anxiety relaxes and
that's going to bring me to betatization
and frame because they're kind of
interconnected so the next point is beta
cization through a thousand sessions
at no point when you're dating a woman
is she going to come over to your house
and say Rich you can't put your socks in
that laundry hamper because that's the
Brown laundry hamper and you got to put
the dark clothes in the dark hamper and
put your white stuff in the white hamper
because that's where they go
they don't do that when you're dating
they don't do that when you're in a
relationship and living in two separate
homes they don't bother you with those
things
so that's a process known as
betatization through a thousand
concessions but your white socks in a
white hamper put your dark socks in a
dark Amber don't brush your teeth over
there you're going to get toothpaste on
the carpet okay that's betaization
through a thousand concessions and each
time you make a little concession
yielding to her with that little
[ __ ] thing oh don't put the
Tupperware over here and the lids have
to go over here and it's got to be
stacked like this or why can't you put
the toilet seat down right
that's betaization through a thousand
sessions by the time you make those
thousand concessions like the guy
mentioned earlier when he started doing
chores and she didn't really want
anything to do with them and ended up
cheating on him women become less
interested in you because you will
betatize yourself it doesn't matter if
you start out as an unplugged Alpha it
is not a question as to whether or not
you will be beta ties it is to what
extent
and how much you will resist it even I
have to resist betaization through a
thousand concessions when I'm dealing
with my girlfriend okay she doesn't live
with me there's a reason for that
makes your life easier
for both of you and trust me you're
going to like each other a lot more take
it like whatever a chick starts to
pressure you to like live together
here's a little challenge for you
take a look around it everybody she
knows
parents Aunts Uncles cousins friends
and then just take a look around be like
okay well there's this this couple this
couple this couple this couple and you
get like you know 10 20 of them you'll
be like how many of them are like
truthfully like ecstatically happy with
one another like deeply in love that
have been together for let's say more
than five to seven years the answer
almost always is going to be almost none
of them or maybe one
so if you're telling me that one out of
20 can make it what what chances do you
think that we're going to be able to
figure it out even a guy like me that
has frame that understands you know a
lot of these Concepts that I talk about
it just makes better sense not to invite
or complicate my life unnecessarily and
dispense energy and resources trying to
maintain higher levels of frame so I
don't get beta ties so I don't have to
listen to [ __ ] about toilet seats or why
can't you stack the Tupperware properly
in the cupboard like the way that I do
it
that you follow me here so far so
betaization's a real threat again that
kind of ties into competition anxiety
which brings me to the next point which
is frame
in every relationship one person enters
the other person's frame if you move
into her house you're entering her frame
if she moves into your house technically
she should be entering your frame
you move into a place together she
should be entering into your frame even
if you move in it like if I were to move
into a chick's house let's be honest I
would be that guy would be like no
you're entering my frame but I wouldn't
do it but
that would be how it would have to be
done if it could be done which is really
almost like an impossibility but that's
how
this guy would do it right because I'm
that guy so frame is
maintaining the fact that she is a
compliment to your life
that's it
there's no complexity she's not here to
complicate your life you know
it it's it's an easy equation
easy life hard deck not the other way
around
okay you want easy life and
you're going to have to increase it
doesn't matter how good of a chick she
is it really doesn't okay she could be
the best chick in the world 10 out of 10
no red flags
all green flags
as soon as you live together the amount
of frame control that you use in the
relationship is going to have to go up
dramatically
now if you like doing that if you like
playing games if you like dealing with
[ __ ] tests if you like you know
enforcing boundaries more often then
invite a chick to live with you because
it's it's going to be more work there's
only 24 hours in a day I have a chapter
in my book that talks about managing
managing your [ __ ] and dispensing your
energy for things are only truly
fuckworthy so I've got stuff I got to do
there's a business that I that I gotta
run there's multiple business I gotta
run there's things that I got to do with
my life that require my energy focus and
attention and if I take
you know if I take away from that
because I have to manage frame in a
live-in long-term relationship then
there's less attention and resources to
do those things
it's like again there's only 24 hours in
a day and then there's 60 60 minutes in
an hour and there's 24 of those hours in
one day so every time you're you know
subtracting a couple minutes to deal
with this [ __ ] or maybe an hour
because there's a big blow up over some
other [ __ ]
you are you are stealing that from your
purpose you're stealing that from
chasing Excellence to deal with
something that is easier to maintain if
you just maintain two separate
households
I'm not opposed to living to a woman
living with a woman let me just make
that clear I'm not opposed to it but it
has to be on my terms
and it's got to be with her entering my
frame being a total compliment to my
life with no [ __ ]
which is going to be very very difficult
to achieve so if we're being honest the
amount of effort and resources that you
apply to being on your grind is going to
offer you a greater Roi and trust me
guys you know a lot of women don't like
to hear this there's women probably
watching this right now maybe even my
check is watching right now she's being
called chick but I call her chick anyway
because that's how I run frame
oh my God
truth of the matter is she's actually
going to likely be happier maintaining
her own household she can decorate the
[ __ ] place however she wants with the
Fufu and the crystals and the energy
[ __ ] over here and the candle and
she can put 27 [ __ ] pillows on her
bed okay
that's what women like to do
right women like to do that stuff let
them have their space let them let them
do that right
I like going over my chick's house it's
very feminine and fufuy and stuff like
that but I love coming back to my place
so there's Freight right you are going
to have to increase the amount of time
effort and resources that you apply to
managing frame in a long-term
relationship if you live together less
so if you're not living together you
still need to use frame but you will
need to exert less energy on it so
accomplishing anxiety betaization and
frame and the last issue is legal issues
which is a pretty complex one and if
we're being honest can be quite [ __ ]
costly for a lot of guys generally
speaking women date across and up on the
socioeconomic scale which means they're
going to date a guy that's better off
than them women don't like to get into
long-term relationships with guys that
are broke they'll bang them they'll have
fun with them they'll become friends
with benefits or some [ __ ] like that but
they don't like to hey I'd like to you
know introduce you to my family I'd like
you to introduce you to my nieces and
nephews and all sort of stuff women
don't generally do that they like to
date across and up on the socioeconomic
scale so the chances of you being with a
chick that's equal to you or make more
than you is an almost impossibility in
today's world you're almost always going
to be better off than she is which means
you now expose your assets to the court
system under family law there's this
concept called common law here where I
live it's after two years in other
places in the world could be five could
be seven years you know you have to
check with a lawyer where where you live
but when the government
decides that you're now not married
so here if I were to live with my chick
for two years and a day and she said
[ __ ] this I'm out she could technically
take half my [ __ ] okay
there's more to it than just that
obviously but
technically a woman has rights to your
assets it's funny there was a uh there
was a it's not even funny but there was
a video that I did
um
there's about two or three years ago
there was a very
affluent
family here in Canada actually in
Toronto I wish I queued up this video so
I could talk about a little more
detail but this but this guy he was in
his 50s very [ __ ] affluent family
billionaire like the family was worth
billions of dollars like if you were to
look up the top 100 richest families in
Canada he was he was up like his family
name was on the list I think they were
like in the 50s or something like that
and this [ __ ] stupid guy
was dating the single mom and they
maintained two separate households now
this is the way that law works here in
Canada so even if you don't live
together it can be quite risky but even
though they maintained two separate
households because he ended up spending
so much time with her taking her down to
Florida taking her to the Muskoka Lakes
um he actually gave her a ring and there
was a photograph uh saying that they
were
engaged or married I can't remember what
the exact details were but blah blah
blah fast forward they they broke up but
because the court saw that they spent so
much time together
with him taking her on trips and
vacations and up at his lake house and
down in Florida you know down in the
condo in the winter time
they deemed that relationship as a a
marriage even though they never had a
ceremony they never took vows and they
never technically lived under the same
roof together she always maintained her
own household because her kids were in a
school zone but he would spend so much
time going over there having dinner them
coming over to his place he would fly
all them down to [ __ ] Florida you
know going up to the lake house
this [ __ ] guy had to maintain a
massive amount of money so many of the
comments is going to write the guy's
name somebody please live comments
somebody
I'll look for it but it'll be in the
final comments at the end this guy had
to cough up huge bucks even though he
never married this chick but because
they were in a long-term relationship
and lived in such a way that looked like
a marriage to the government they called
it a marriage and he ended up having to
maintain her [ __ ] lifestyle after
that so you don't have to live together
that's how [ __ ] up law is in countries
like Canada but the truth of matter is
you can put together a cohabitation
agreement which by the way loses its
Effectiveness over time so the longer
you're together the less relevant it
becomes it's relevant for a few years 10
years down the road not so much depends
how circumstances change and unwind this
is why my lawyer is just like it's just
not worth the hassle it's just simpler
it's easier for us to love each other we
have a better time with one another
right you know like it's just a reality
of the world today like if living
together is such a great idea why did I
have 450 comments but I could only find
two and again I I asked the question in
a very balanced way why did I only find
two people that praised their long-term
relationship
right it doesn't work out for most guys
so there's the legal issue thing could
you protect it with a cohabitation
agreement possibly over a long period of
time not so much
um but you're always going to be exposed
to that risk because again women don't
date down they only like to date up they
want to move into
they want to be invited into your world
right you're not going to go to their
you know bus pass club she's going to
come to your exotic car club and hang
out with you and your friends right
that's that's what women do right
um that's not that's not a bug that's a
feature of women if if they weren't
hypergamous they like we would not be so
successful as a species women needed to
find the best possible guy that they
could find for her and her children to
survive it's always been that way
throughout history and here we are in
today's modern times with family law and
the government get involved in your
[ __ ] life as they always like to do
and interfering with your [ __ ] and
that's just the way that it is so keep
those four points in mind because those
are really the main ones competition
anxiety decreases which means they're
interested in you will decrease which is
which is tied into why so many guys
reported a uh a strong decrease in
intimacy or levels of intimacy or the
enthusiasm in which intimacy would occur
bit ofization she's going to become less
interested in you as part of a result of
that you know as a consequence it's part
of the intermingling of all that so
you're going to have to have strong
frame you know the third point
and then you've got the legal issue so
that's that's the main stuff hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out